pascal pourquoi est ce que vous avez eu
envie de changer de décor et d'emmener
ces jeunes là au bout du monde là
simplement pour qu'ils puissent se
diriger vers les autres parce que c'est
vrai que quand on est à domicile on a
tout le confort on a internet et
télévision ont fait un petit peu ce
qu'on veut on peut sortir à notre guise
alors que là bas il ya plus rien j'ai
les coupes du monde de la réalité en
tout cas est en fait ils deviennent avec
avec cette aventure qu'on a vécu
ensemble déjà un petit peu plus ouvert
aux autres et puis c'était justement
travail de l'ouverture d'esprit le
dépassement de soi d'accord prochain
numéro vous pouvez pas emmener mathieu
de lamballe on parle bien frais du
bourget un poème à résoudre a qu'une et
les maîtrise et 17h45
non j'adore parce qu'à dont je vais être
très honnête j'en ai marre toujours de
ces phénomènes de mode donc évolué en
terrain connu avec lopez il ya eu mike
horn diatta ya sur tf1 christophe
dechavanne qu'à faire une émission
maintenant toi aussi ça y est on est
dans la mode maintenant déclare problème
on ne mène quelqu'un à l'autre bout du
monde et parce qu'il est au milieu des
vaches et des inconnus on va résoudre le
premier l'a alors toujours ces phénomène
de mimétisme à la télévision un truc
marche on duplique ça m'agace un peu
sow venait là effectivement on emmène
des jeunes gens en difficulté alors que
dans les autres cas car c'était rien à
voir là ils viennent gérer des conflits
avec des adolescents qui sont en
difficulté dans leur famille ça n'a rien
à voir avec les yeux qui font faire un
dépassement de soi pour eux
personnellement et du coup la nsa les
fruits de l'ue message pour les gens qui
ont les preuves dans les familles c'est
emmener vos mômes à s'amuser totalement
pour qu'ils soient plus avec leur ca
propose je vous propose de regarder un
extrait prévoir exactement ce qu'il ce
qui se passe dans cette émission là
c'est le les quatre jeunes qui sont
vraiment devraient eux-mêmes vraiment
allez tout ce qui est autour de vous y'a
rien absolument rien
je regardais le paysage parce que
clairement j'ai paniqué je me suis
limité pour l'aider à reconstruire
nature pouvoir dormir le soir
[Musique]
vous avez vu des montagnes les véhicules
peuvent pas se hisser là où donc on va y
aller à pied sauf que on va pas il est
tout seul c'est quoi je m'étais pression
maintenant être un peu pour le coup il
est honnête on regarde si on ma vie je
vois plus je mange plus comme ça du top
6 j'ai senti qu'il était totalement
déstabilisé dès le début quand vous avez
complètement 7000 kilomètres de chez eux
certaines n'ont jamais pris l'avion donc
c'est pour aussi une première et pour
rejoindre un petit peu ce que disait un
mathieu ont fait pas de la copie se
seront fait pas du copier coller là on
est vraiment soit 4 matic différentes et
les quatre sont là pour s'entraider
entre ce que ce convoi panneaux et
autres émissions effectivement de voyage
aussi loin c'est plutôt une recherche
avec soi-même exactement découverte de
soi oui gilles et bien entendu mathieu
se trompe totalement là ça va pas être
larmoyant comme du frédéric lopez qui
est insupportable
on va se servir sur le dos des
populations autochtones comme le faisait
pendant des années rendez vous en terre
inconnue non ça va être j'en suis sûr
avec pascal de la sincérité
on va aller regarder les autres comment
ils vivent et pas se servir sur le dos
de la bête moi j'adore cette émission
avant même de l'avoir vu